[Music]
competition
is built on rivalry the best stories in
esports are about
two great players vying for glory
constantly outdoing the other in pursuit
of victory
this is is not that kind of story
expected was the better player ocelot
was the better performer
and personality and everybody knew it
and he hated it when we played the first
times
i thought that he was a really good but
then i think
i became way better and at some point
i didn't see him as a as a
big rival anymore i remember telling to
myself this guy is really [ __ ] lucky
i would still have every now and then
some nightmares about the [ __ ]
[Applause]
backdoor
at some point i was not thinking any
longer about the game all the time
and i was thinking about other things
like you know i want to build
something there is no chance to yell
comes back from this
they're already of the nexus turrets
this is what
peak league of legends looks like and it
comes
from europe it's not about the opponent
failing it's about you
proving to yourself and those that
follow you that you have it in you
to build something that succeeds this is
the story
of a rivalry that exists exclusively in
fans heads
a rivalry that was never anything but
one-sided a rivalry that despite
barely being real defined european
league of legends
for years and to be honest it's
hard to even really call it a rivalry
anymore
what ocelot has been able to do with g2
esports
blows pekka and origins accomplishments
and success out the water
by such a massive margin that it's
offensive to call it a rivalry
i i know i'm i know i'm making into that
piece
[Music]
carlos ocelot rodriguez and enrique
expecio martinez are not bitter rivals
in fact these days they barely think
about each other
i mean i think about it like for me
it's it's not it's not like a rivalry
that big how do you feel about pekke now
do you even think about him when you're
do you know like back to those days at
all no i
no i i don't man but just a few years
ago it was
impossible to talk about european league
of legends and
not talk about xpeke and ocelot the
league's two
star spanish midlaners but ocelot and
ex-pekka's rivalry didn't start as a
continent-defining battle for glory it
started with two dudes who just couldn't
stop running into each other
i remember the very beginning of esports
in league of legends was go for loss
which is
the esl weekly tournament that happened
in our league of legends
and in that tournament we always fought
in the final it was like very often we
fought against
each other you know my team against
biggest team my team against pakistan
and at the very beginning we always beat
them and then
when things got a little bit more
serious without playing tournaments they
started beating us a little bit more
often
and yeah that that rivalry kind of got
bored you know
it was pretty natural for the fans to
start seeing them as rivals
they were both spanish both played mid
and they were both
rising stars in the early days of
european league
but that's pretty much where the
comparison ended
see ocelot was a showman he knew the
value of talking trash and being funny
on stream
no worries i got you
very nice but xpeke dominated in game
he was a mid lane god eventually taking
on some of
the best players in the world fights def
just finishes trinity force
got his gun shadow used brutalizer it's
all about fighting fights death
going down but is it going to be enough
study is going
played for fnatic going all the way back
to 2011 when he helped them win the
first ever league of legends world
championship one turret is down they're
gonna back off for now lena taking a lot
of damage from ash 300 300 300 damage
crits are out there
that was one turret dead second to
attack going to win the season
one championship if they can hold on
this nexus
will go down congratulations to fanatic
winning the season one
meanwhile ocelot was a great player who
just sort of refused to adapt
in real life i'm the most athletic
person but in game i have only
one gear and that is aggression you know
now ocelot's career started around the
same time as x-pec is but
his just didn't take off the same way he
signed with sk gaming and they
did fine jim bones get stunned up there
type coming in to finish but kha'zix
jumps into the middle of them
not for long though he is destroyed the
wild growth was on candy finer as well
that will be a three for nothing by the
time the eu lcs rolled around in 2013
sk were a strong team but struggled to
take out the best rosters in the region
but ocelot and pekka's clashes were the
stuff
of legend every league fan looked
forward to fnatic
and sk facing off a matchup that was
dubbed
el clasico it was a lot of fun because
back in the day
fnatic versus sk was one of the most
competitive matches that you could have
watched
and historically fnatic versus sk in
every other esport was also
exceptionally competitive
um their counter-strike 1.6 teams were
very very good
i was a huge fan of their quake players
who regularly made top 8 placements
and the esports industry was
significantly smaller
with less games so it meant that
you tended to be more aware of all of
these other matches and all these other
events that were happening so
it used to be called el clasico the fact
that it was two spanish players
competing against one another
and referencing obviously the the team
the football team sharing in europe
and it was this pair who also gave
league of legends
one of its greatest moments at iem
katowice 2013 sk were about to take
fnatic out
when peke went for a historic heroic
backdoor to win the game and create
one of the most famous clips in league
down is history gonna be able to deal
with this one catches him with another x
he's very low
[Music]
yeah obviously ocelot wasn't thrilled
about that one
but him and peke kept it very classic
we are just destroyed right now as a
team
we are destroyed because i think we
played good we wanted to show the world
we should want to show the fans and
ourselves
so we are one of the best teams of the
world already
[Music]
and uh we failed we failed uh just
before we
wrapped that up expected you want to say
something yeah the way you play today
you are definitely a tough team in the
world
and moments like that are why people
loved their rivalry so much
two players who had nothing but respect
for one another
big personalities and even bigger
hearts as the years went on ex-pekka
kept up his level of excellence
winning the first three eu lcs playoffs
in a row
but sk was rapidly losing steam
they finished fourth in the 2013 spring
playoffs then didn't
qualify for summer and that's around the
time that ocelot realized that he just
wasn't in love with league anymore at
some point i was not thinking any longer
about the game all the time
and i was thinking about other things
like you know i want to build
something i want to learn you know how
to build a company i want to learn
different things i want you know i want
to eventually have a wife you know i
want to mention that
i want to build a family i want to be
obsessed with something else you know
and that
realization came on my last year as a
player it was very clear to me that
i didn't have the drive to be the number
one in game anymore
but i did have the drive to be the
number one outside of the game
so ocelot left sk gaming to found his
own roster gamers 2 which
let's be honest sounds a lot more like
one of those shady cs go case opening
sites than an esports organization
[Music]
anyway the first year was rough
ocelot was still playing mid and the
team struggled to qualify for the lcs
without making much headway
and then his old rival peke came to town
i remember even when i when i when i
started playing i had this
this idea that i wanted to make like my
own team because i used to play
games like wow or any other games and
you have like your clan
i wanted to make something similar to
that like make your team with your group
of people that your friends
and make it together expect founded
origin
he was done with playing for someone
else's team he wanted the glory for
himself
so he gathered some of the biggest
talents in the european league and
started from the bottom
now origen had to qualify for challenger
and then
win that league just to make it back
into the lcs
but peke didn't let a challenge like
that stop him
oh pekka is on the base it doesn't
matter though because everyone is dying
four versus five are winning
is pecking the nexus this will be going
down here stress
and origen welcome to the lcs because
you've just dominated this series
you've taken the first place in the
spring split
of the challenger series congratulations
super minions will be pouring through
and for origen
three inhibitors down looking for 3-0
to take down the unicorns of love the
european
regional third place seed is about to be
finalized the second best team in europe
origen pushing fnatic all the way
getting pushed by rockets
obliterate unicorns of love and
book their tickets to paris another
couple of kills come through as steak
has nowhere to go
a few more shots will do it the kills
come in
and this could be the semifinals for
origen there's only one man left alive
this will surely be the base in europe
has a semi finalist in the world
championship as origin with 3-1
after the first year i felt like i
achieved
everything that i wanted to achieve in
the next three or four years like
i didn't think that we would go to
worlds in the first year like
qualifying for lcs was already like the
success for me that year and then going
to walls
next year or the year after would have
been great so doing it doing all of that
in one year
it just felt unreal and yeah it pretty
much felt like a dream to me that
everything that i wanted
happened so fast origen bulldozed their
way through
challenger and the eu lcs all to make
top four at worlds in their first year
expected took his rivalry with ocelot
out behind the woodshed
and put it out of its misery he had
beaten him as a player
and as a team owner and manager now that
should have been the final word in the
ocelot versus
xpeke rivalry that should have been the
end
but it wasn't i i had in my mind
um only one thing in mind which is
qualified for the lcs right
nothing else in my mind and i even went
incredibly quiet i was like no social
media
no streaming no nothing i want to just
be i want to learn
and i want to succeed you know and then
i will get known again
ocelot and the redubbed g2 kept grinding
out impressive results throughout the
spring split
and eventually they found themselves
face to face with ex pekka and origen
in the finals and it was here on
europe's biggest stage
that ocelot was finally able to exact
some revenge
power of evil twisted manson he may not
last for long or rather it's the base
that g2 have set their sights on
and in 35 minutes not without mistakes
but they demolish origin and make a huge
statement here in rotterdam
well turn back to perks oh okay
judging by the pinks he actually hit
that one on power people by the way did
power
is going to fall oh so low as kick as
chrono breaks back in
howard's gonna get slain and emperor
gets the credit mythian amazing nearly
falls
this is gonna be g2 trying to press
their advantage here how far can they
take this
they now turn their attention back
towards the nexus turrets or rather onto
amazing who burns his flash
so as though will answer back to hybrid
amazing is gonna get batted away by
kikis
to dominate this one so as back to
fountain
will it even keep him alive it looks
like it but it doesn't matter if the
nexus is going down
and g2 once again take on a huge
convincing victory
such a tense moment here origen trying
to hang firm death mark already back up
they turn their attention to his van
perks going way too low
oh he's gonna grab another kill it's
amazing and so
that's the last nexus turret that's
gonna be it we have a new king in europe
after all
2015 they proved they were lcs material
it felt [ __ ] great because it's not
about the opponent failing it's about
you
proving to yourself and those that
follow you that you have it in you to
build something
that succeeds you know it's about
reinventing yourself and feeling
so powerful like right now man
i feel so powerful in the sense of
there's nothing that can happen that can
kill me
except if i die right there's nothing
else from there
g2 went on to also win the summer split
qualifying for worlds in their first
year but in the wake of g2's tremendous
success
origin fell off pretty hard they went
from finishing
second in the spring playoffs to going 0
and 13 in the summer season it was among
the worst
splits in league history and it meant
they had to play in summer promotion
where they got booted back to challenger
after an 03 loss to
giants an org that was less of a league
team
and more of a perennial punchline adding
insult to injury
g2 jacked origins bot lane out from
under them
won four straight playoffs and made it
to worlds
again all of a sudden it looked like
ocelot would have the
final word in the rivalry if you could
even call of that anymore
what ocelot has been able to do with g2
esports
blows pekka and origins accomplishments
and success
out the water by such a massive margin
that it's offensive to call it a rivalry
origin fell off about as hard as any
league team
can in between the constant losses
expected was in and out of the team
playing mid
then coaching then coming back to play
support then aidy carrie
then support again but no matter where
he ended up it didn't go to plan
power secures the kill sinks his fangs
in onto a sing but now he's isolated
from the team
caught in a cocoon it comes to viking
power goes gold and soaz trying to
provide the backup will he be able to do
it peki flash
over
it shut down for so as misfits are the
ones who are starting to get turned on
and peke
will fall peke went from top four at
worlds
to second last in challenger
it was a remarkable fall from grace for
one of league's most iconic players and
by 2017
he'd had enough and decided to step away
as a competitor for good
meanwhile g2 were on top of the world
and if you asked ocelot about his old
rival
all he could really say was
who if you asked me like five six years
ago i would still have every now and
then some nightmares about the [ __ ]
backdoor
but but i no longer do i mean i
never i mean it's just i don't even
think about it you know
now i have uh i have different people on
my radar
memory is pretty short in the esports
world as
g2 rose meteorically origin didn't just
fall they were forgotten eu league fans
were too busy being
mad at g2 for either not practicing
enough for msi
or trash talking other teams or just
winning too much
but the story couldn't have been more
different for expect and origin
after bombing out of challenger the team
disbanded
all that was left was expect and the
brand for whatever that was worth at
that point
until 2019 when some big money came a
knock in
and origen were given a new lease on
life
[Music]
oh man big sigh coming out of the origin
representative here in the tub water
might just be a little bit too hot for
ex peke real question is though
how long before he subs himself back
into the main roster
[Music]
refresh entertainment then the owners of
astralis
the best cs go team ever bought a spot
in the newly franchised lec
and they also bought the origin brand to
go with it
bringing the long lost fan favorite team
back to life and their ex becca was
along for the ride currently i'm more of
a brand ambassador with the team
of course i also help with anything that
with any questions that they have about
the branding about players i try to help
as much as i can
but of course of course i'm more
disconnected from the players as i was
before
i i don't play nearly as much i don't i
only watch
or games and a few more and origen
didn't do half bad in their return to
competition taking second place in the
2019 spring playoffs their first split
back
of course they did lose to g2 giving
fans their first taste of the
legendary rivalry in years all of that
gold all of those towers that they've
taken down
ladies and gentlemen twitch chat press f
to pay respects because og's funeral is
coming up
these days neither pekka nor ocelot play
for the teams they found it
they aren't necessarily involved in the
day-to-day operations of
running those league rosters but the
memory of their legendary rivalry has
managed to transcend
all of that now expected and ocelot
themselves may never face off again
but el clasico lives on forever
because every time i open twitter i see
comments and i'm sure
he he does as well like the fans just
keep
bringing it up so i don't know what he's
doing exactly but
um i wish him the best and i when i
think about packing right now i just
think about i
think about him as a nice guy that was
incredibly skilled about the game of the
game in the game
that i think under leveraged his
position
we haven't we haven't played the game
for a long time like
we are yeah it has nothing to do with
our level it has to do with the fact
that
we just founded these teams and now the
10 players are playing and i think i
think that's pretty cool as well because
you don't really get that in many places
like you don't see
every team and then you suddenly realize
think about oh my god this team 10 years
ago played against this team that
doesn't happen much and i think that's
that's pretty cool
to be honest too to just be remembered
all the time
for something of the past i think that's
really nice
[Music]
a shady key yes
shady key reseller it was embarrassing
[ __ ] humiliating it was [ __ ]
shameful it should be origen i'm like a
little bit of a stickler for stuff like
that but it's i'm just i'm not going to
win
esports is you can't win in esports
don't even get me started on on nature
and
sarah don't even get me [ __ ] started
jason
all right i don't know don't even get me
started
this is this is this is something that's
a conversation that's happened in the
office many times